[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody oh hey Rob hi okay it's
kind of late in the day but uh destiny
servers were down till about 2:00 p.m.
and so we also had another live stream
for Call of Duty earlier so here we are
duh this is our first inaugural
Destiny's children stream we'll be doing
that every Tuesday the UK covers that on
Fridays they do a long play series we do
some live streaming we do Tuesday resets
destiny - that's what's today so you
guys are gonna get to check that out we
are gonna do the nightfall
and then also we'll do some other stuff
it's start wrapping up our clan XP cuz
it's a game spa that has a clan our clan
rosters are finally working which is
cool now I can actually see people on
there oh that's nice part of the update
so exactly and guided games got added -
it's a beta and only select or certain
people actually got invited to that
program so that's that so if you got
into guy 2 games cool if you didn't
sorry
hopefully it gets through beta for you
and you guys can get in so I need to
change my input here to my game because
2 of us are playing today
yeah that's rare yeah so we got Aaron
Sampson who's kind of a ok light 2:57
you're like 266 I just sent you an
invite Rob okay so no excuse I've gotten
three of these stupid portal shotguns
I'm really sick of them and they're
really upsetting to me honest but uh
yeah that's me
Titan 288 probably gonna hit 290 Plus
this week you dog once we get through
some of this powerful stuff yeah so that
we can get this all this purple stuff on
the left there there's like four pieces
to get we're gonna go do this strike the
strike or the sorry the nightfall the
nightfall this week is a murdered spire
it's got prism again which is like Oh
actually what weapons do you have
we're gonna need to make sure we kind of
got some different archetypes here sure
sure sure yeah
so you know how this goes actually you
didn't do the first night fall so you
should tell me let me give you a quick
hint here so it's gonna cycle through
different elements and when it does it
does it for a minute okay and in that
minute like let's say it says solar as
erupted right that means all your solar
damage from your son shot for example is
gonna do like I would say double I
that's the exact number was gonna do
more damage okay
and then if it's arc it's arc if it's
void its void so like ideally you don't
want to go double solar here so maybe
you can chart maybe go back up use your
277 sorry yeah
use your cold heart and then can do if
you don't have void right which you
don't have right now you can't see it on
his screen actually let me expect him
and you'll be able to see it look at me
I'm totally looking at his screen and
you guys could too if I just did this
man here we go
so if it doesn't do if it's Boyd right
what you should do is shoot just with
your kinetic okay and don't bother
switching yeah don't bother switching
mid find the fly so just use it when you
have it when it's the right one I'll try
to make the call out and then if it's
not then use your kinetic fair enough so
you're like a rockin stormcaller that's
probably pretty good
I'm gonna go Sentinel I don't know what
Aaron is aaron has it done and I fall
either there's gonna be tough because
he's delayed so he's void chances are
he's gonna pop supers and stuff without
us knowing is my guess also just so you
know Rob this is timed so we kind of got
a book it a little bit okay so good luck
to us so I should probably hit up these
abilities to four which are more like
pertaining to team play right like oh my
stuff I can swap it it's up to you which
one you want to do I think that one's
better Chain Lightning get more damage
across the board fair enough I can't
quite hear game on I know I can't either
oh you know what it is well it's my
settings I at home was having a lot of
issues with my sound being too loud
but I'll turn it up a bit there's that
sweet sweetness like just as we need use
the sniper that changes elements says
Bob Jones I don't have borealis which is
the PlayStation 4 exclusive sniper that
you can toggle different elements same
with hard light now you can toggle
different elements all right so this is
the same strike as beta Rob if you did
that strike mm-hmm except we're on a
timer and we got to do that stuff that I
mentioned this is awkward black screen
there we go 250 clinics but you I don't
even know why we got to go though there
we go
also guys will be monitoring chat to the
best of our ability so if you're in chat
hit us up and we will do our best to
respond arc-flash
Rob so your Ark your secondary Ark is
gonna do a lot more now I already got a
legendary that's cool and you'll notice
that it's gonna do more than normal
I like how Aaron is dancing and doing
absolutely nothing to help us great
I also didn't inspect it okay so we'll
see some platforming solar now robbed so
if you have solar later you could use a
rocket or something to do more damage
already right Oh
the other thing we can do to later on
the boss can kind of go ham on him at
certain phases with the supers that we
have because it'll do a lot more damage
to them but we also have to be mindful
and careful because it's possible that
uh he's gonna have a quite a bit again
interesting that you're kind of just out
in the public with these randos I was
about to say that either
this isn't this isn't the raid also it's
a void now so I would use something
other than that solar that aim is using
is less effective yeah I'm just gonna
connect good job so you have us I'm
using kinetic as well I have solar in
art we have no void but I could swap to
avoid these dead in a second oh I don't
know let's just keep going rob cool I
don't know how he died back there but
it's Ark now if you have use your cold
parts cool cuz you're a cold-hearted man
got cold ha yeah I was gonna try to see
if I could bring out our sparrow but no
can do yeah there was a there's a
striker to the other night that like
it's interesting has certain areas where
you can get away with a little sparrow
action what are we waiting on here that
is weird we should have been able to go
through what see did you bug out because
of that other here we go I think it's
solar now so user kinetic
oh no Rob okay nice guy oh we're not
gaining time right now that's right
because we only gain time from running
through the circles later that's the
other modifier this week is rings oh no
we'll see that later and basically what
we want to do is kill all the ads yeah
no I don't have Boyd I can swap it
though if you don't have it all right
okay
I'm gonna die too
oh you know why cuz he's boy damage I
can swap right now two boys
did I not work so die a four-second
servers wait I'm getting you know we're
kind of behind time right now but I
think we can make up for it later a
players left our team that's cool can
you revive me behind you in a second I
don't know what Aaron's trying to do
it's a still RoR
oh it's solar now that's why it hurts so
bad don't get sniped or shot too much by
these goblins we do more damage with
solar but so do they I just mean mindful
because those guys are things you can
use all right here we go Boyd good I
mean should one of us have a void weapon
ready but you know that's how the cookie
crumbles sometimes yeah
if been Janka or someone out there is
listening to this stream maybe take
Aaron's spot if he's not gonna come back
can he still join right now yeah I think
so so I forget I haven't done this yet
so I don't know exactly where the rings
are but Ark now so if you want to bring
out your cold hearts that would be the
time used to it I guess I still didn't
fix the prison bug
unless what that was so they were saying
like you know how it says like what it
is right it's supposed to stick it's
supposed to like stay in the bottom left
so you know exactly what it is instead
of having to like remember oh by the way
it's like Ark you know it's not it's not
there right now so we do that's really
weird
anyways someone joined us I don't know
who somebody Barrows here oh okay
so what wheats blow blow plastics guys
what we gotta go we got time to worry
about I like your style we do only have
five minutes as of now I know here's a
trimming muzzle that was a ranch I go
through this ship I guess if you did
then we are try go through it let's do
it
I don't know we're gonna figure it out
so we just gained 30 here's another one
oh damn there's a bunch just try to jump
through as many as you can Rob because
we need to get that time so we need to
push past this next part where the door
is at or where these guys are guarding
it
twitter is better Aaron is good to jump
through these rings soon but we got
seven minutes back I'm gonna keep
jumping somewhere
there Oh God I am taking the big damage
it's also a one-person thing it looks
like no no no she'd be able to disappear
as people they said that multiple people
could go through it but there's multiple
rings I saw you go through one and it
disappeared after that looks like all
the Rings all right so we need to down
here Rob there's a tooth those little
things are gonna shoot us across the way
we need to kill the stuff that's over
here you'll eat security wherever the
hell they are
what's the Toller I got a rock launcher
but it's that's fine it's not much
supposed to be down here
where are they back up there it's
pointing us in a different direction
behind us I guess those two arrows are
where the guys are
so hi
do you see the guy that we yeah there's
it here I'm here I got a super ready
it's void here I'm gonna see for
where's the other dude once we kill him
we can kind of proceed other side my
boys out yeah so if you can get in here
to help you want me to super awesome
no it's Ark I could do it this no no
it's a Ark now yeah but we're good just
use your Ark weapons to kill this guy
cold hurts fire really good all right
good now we can jump through those
thingies so little just avoid that guy
and just go oh he's going anyways oh
that's cool that was cool
oh I landed right on you goddamn me
revive me inside I'm gonna kill myself
doing it it's all good I didn't expect
that that happened no that was
unfortunate maybe you guys could get me
yeah we're gonna move it because there's
two more sections with rings
Boyd we're going down here we got to
fill some stuff go some doshas war
hounds he goes cleaver guys gladiator
they're really strong as one would
expect right are you not entertained
dogs are out I think it's art cool I
like that
this guy's our
okay I just got Cleve
crap jump over and buy beer and I guess
damn trying to uh yes
well I hope that with the rings we can
make it back
I'll probably just wait no no yeah I'm
here I'm gay boy now
I mean it just doesn't even dogs like
using the wrong elemental type will act
like be worse yeah Wow
or it'll do less damage so yes we could
we're going across they think right yeah
it says we can't let's do it
we have 338 right now I think there's
one more section here what what dude I
hate this part I got I should have no I
don't guy you know I should have lived
that jump
I always faceplant that freaking wall
though done that like three times
hello Aaron that's fine happens a lot
dan what gun is that
oh it's at the dig site yeah first time
did we'd met back when we jumped there I
don't think we're gonna make it oh my
god dude oh you died again do I face
plant that wall every time on that on
that jump forget it
okay cool he's got by of course the
circles are here the wall like I said
the key is supposed to be that you kill
everything here and then jump through
those circles so this is pretty much a
wife should wipe it
I will try one more time if it doesn't
hurry and do some other stuff is clearly
he says the delay is really bad yeah
obviously but I'm trying to tell him
that he should probably still like well
the problem is he's so low he probably
has to equip all his highest gear yeah
we're all [ __ ] I don't really want to
use a sniper here
I did not optimized for this guess I'll
use a sniper because oh no you know what
I'll use graviton Lance and then I'll
use a hard rocket
I have void now so you just have to use
solar okay yeah yeah but I'm using that
often I could swap to like my son shot
as my secondary that's fine I like my
sunshine yes that's pretty good
I think cold hearts I mean so I'm
already in this British I'm already in
art class though so I could use I'm
disappointed too Jam to bread but I
could you Eric I could use like my like
arc Rene's and [ __ ] like that right like
that would ya technically yes if it's
art yes I got two first timers Jim Rob's
never done a rich don't hate a nightfall
look not something that's my buddy Wow
285 that mean you won't get any good
gear from rage no I'm actually 288
yeah
Oh
we're gonna have solar anymore just my
rock watching
we got this see we had two minutes there
and we weren't even close to the boss
actually that's not totally true we're
close to the loss actually a weird start
definitely gotta be better with killing
stuff that's for sure
why
and that guy's looks like a problem
Eric's confidence is inspiring yep
that's what happens at four o'clock it's
been a long day
been a long day legitimately a long day
yeah definitely I even got that video
gun right before this did you really
yeah you badass did you talk to Emily
not yet let's find out I might help out
okay see this time it's down earlier
this is the shield thing those well I
think it was those guys are really a
winner earlier yeah ohso there's rings
here let's not go through that the ring
did okay right there boy yeah kill
everything and then enjoy the run our
dream arc right question is can we get
back up here
I can stay up here it's maybe an engage
it yeah yeah sure you stay okay okay boy
and then I'm gonna believe in you to get
to do those thing you just you call it
no we're just gonna kill everything
it must be void it's fine
got to kill all the ads before the Rings
it definitely helps to kill all the ads
before the Rings that's for sure alright
is it art yeah
that kid
so I got this come on
so solar right yeah oh honey I should I
grab it I mean less guys now yeah keep
are there more yeah they're up here
though of course there's one's kind of
near you I got the ones up here who I
got all these yo
Oh what an there's up there too and
below us really oh this is an easy one
then I'll get killed I guess we got to
go yeah screw those things almost as
much as you start with so arc arc okay
cool so I think we [ __ ] that one up
earlier so that's good to know
we didn't get as many rings that like
that first time see we could've kept
doing it it actually said rings collapse
because we left the area okay arc right
we can keep going like we did last time
let's skip these guys okay yep good rats
all right you just keep going well it's
just that if you get filled up here we
can't really yeah I'm good
cuz also just to be careful that it is
solar right now so they're some of these
decks we're gonna do more damage we can
spare Oh
GA Garcia asked we're playing on
Prestige Mode is that the highest is the
300 light one hit these guys go for it
to the left
Aaron close to me bad no hella deuce
your left solar I go supercharged puck
go ahead just do it even though it's not
or kill that guy yeah I'll work on the
other one it's not random right the
health ailments changing order always on
order yeah I need you guys to help kill
this morning after your banner boy
they're ready to run okay yeah goats
goats through that grille oh my god
again I got you yeah it excited I'm so
stupid
it's art
use my I use my hot milk I like it yeah
that's crazy it happen again skip these
guys it's art oh my god the rocket with
you
like a waste of two rockets but yeah oh
come on a secondary boost and engaged so
I just took a lot of fall damage I'm
chillin it's all dirt right now
Solar is it solar yeah I just trench so
I don't have solar and these guys were
solar I got out of solar so I think too
much
boid
dogs
please please be our soon Oh yours love
I think it's line up okay are we good
let's go let's go let's go
are you guys good oh yeah
remember this one don't place man oh god
I just stayed fighting myself
dude I hate that stuff at least I lived
Oh
like I said that and then I did it shai
using my rocket on the student all the
way I guess yeah one no no I'll get the
next let's go we gotta go okay
cuz we need a make up time on the drill
part with Rings the Rings yeah well we
got to kill everything I think because I
don't think we're gonna make it to
because the drill is probably gonna kill
us a couple times with my guess yeah am
i super ready
what is it what is it right now super
now it's Boyd
call you call my super if you want you
know what just her narc let's go we
gotta go
I shouldn't have even I should have just
had us go we got to kill this stuff
though I guess and then go through the
rings it possible
unless chat knows something that I don't
know feel like there's a lot of stuff
we're supposed to like I mean should I
should you move ahead I'll wait back on
this like last time I mean I want to get
as many rings as possible at this point
you know right but like if we kill all
these some goes ahead and kills all
these dudes in front of us all right
I hope Aaron's listening well I'll hang
back
[ __ ] I'm at a kinetic ammo don't die to
that thing I'm gonna go down I'm gonna
go left
all right go up
okay
it's just so nerve-racking I missed it
down oh no I tried oh all right
Oh where'd you come from get those rings
if you can Rob don't even try to revive
me get the rings all right just go to
the boss wait for me
we have for mystical applause maybe we
can go
so just keep moving yeah yeah yeah just
go we got to go after the box now we
have three minutes thirty seconds to
kind of go ham on him
I don't know I read that something like
you could go through the things multiple
times but you can't so it's weird that
you can't keep moving yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm just uh no you're good
we just got to really kill this guy fast
so when it's like a certain element
later like arc I might just have you pop
super not here but after this okay okay
doesn't matter what is it I have no idea
oh yeah milk does melt those you got the
cold our baby
alright the boss is gonna spawn here
still are yes
I'll wait till next round of suit of
elements to do my super yeah next time
oh he's next in living him he's next to
err
it's solar I got my Rockets can you rock
at the boss when you have time
yeah just worry about your survival for
now I'm trying to push it yeah we're
pushing him to the next phase that's
fine he's gonna teleport down now okay
or we're gonna get teleported rather all
right so just be careful here and then
whatever element it is the one of us is
gonna fly out so it's boy I'm gonna
super him right when he is available
okay also know that the ground lights
off
switching guns keep DPS mmm
it's art oh I just got shy do it super
it yeah yeah do it do it do it
Aaron revive me if you can hear this
just keep keep holding it down krob yep
oh he died after your supers outcome
revive me or now's a good time because
you're gonna drop down teleport we got a
minute
Aaron if you can hear this I need you to
Sentinel super him later when he's void
although I don't even know if it's gonna
go to boys
Solar solar you have Rockets not out
maybe these guys could cough up
something yeah he's over here now we'll
see you 35 seconds when it goes Boyd we
just gotta go it's Boyd Aaron if you
have Sentinel please please go in
okay it's a wife dang I was pretty close
little close sweet better if your
hammers there yeah but would we switch
anything up I'll try to go hammers I
guess it really doesn't help that he's
not like in the chat to communicate yeah
he killed 27 things so what's in the
chat like should we have each different
supers right yeah I'm gonna go solar
so okay
it's all good now that actually was
fairly good progress I thought I mean
I'm sore toes I mean it was close
ideally so like ideally you want to have
like five minutes on the boss yeah and
if we had five minutes we'd probably
kill them but we did not have five
minutes so anything I should change up
you think no I think you're good I think
we're good in terms of like our weapon
compositions now but you know I'll
switch to solar and hopefully that does
some stuff
yeah we needed when we were void when
we're it was both when it was void we
but me and Aaron both needed to let go
ham on him with our supers cuz you can
pretty much with this prism you can
pretty much go ham with super that's
kind of a point like when you did you're
you're super you pretty much took off
like you know like almost like one
square yourself so that's the ideal goal
right straight off we weren't that close
J Garcia to be honest he had a whole bar
like he was a little under his third bar
with like 30 seconds that's why my foes
anything just by some areas we're just
gonna have to like run by like that one
part where there's like the fire guys up
top and stuff like that and then we can
just run by those guys to get to the
drill talk about yeah I do
we kind of spent those we just got
[ __ ] okay to leave this food here
because they just did the thing and now
we have to wait for this stuff to
respawn that's really dumb but it that's
yeah why can't it like separate groups
I mean she's restart right yeah I guess
so since we need every bit of time I
guess so I don't I don't want to think
about it you know when we're doing it
yeah or like beef three seconds off or
some [ __ ]
yeah stuff I believe this is the run
this is a real chance yeah at least six
3jm 76 singing well that's horrible yeah
it's it's pretty much like when those
other groups went through the little
like shielded thing to like it pretty
much was not a good time
we're good
I think we'll see it's like one of those
things were like to be honest I wish I
could just use my my solar fusion but
kind of gotta have some different weapon
comps mm-hmm hey y'all the Sanchez plant
the PC I can't hand a little suede yeah
you know that's been so lame watch out
that guys
Ark put the big guy is he still around
I killed the big guy
come on are you hacking it yep come on
game you want to just run by the next
group of people sure Aaron I hope you
hear this we're straight running wait
where is there see his triangle is hella
far back Aaron what are you mean you rob
I guess can we stop him oh I'm gonna run
through this okay all right we just
gotta hope tonight okay you know what
this could be a terrible idea by the way
real talk this is a bad idea I guess we
have to kill it I didn't want to I guess
we don't have a choice
also I don't know where Aaron that redu
yeah that's fine do it now
he just texted I can't follow you bugged
you got bugged apparently hang in there
oh [ __ ] okay
dude I'm just gonna call him an iPhone
you just listen to me
right sure
so outside of the nightfall there's a
bunch of stuff you could do flashpoints
the necess
it's an SS flashpoints this week message
trade net trade Kade treasure maps so
check those out obviously all Rob makes
a call
but yeah don't forget guys Destiny's
children
it's our first live stream of that sorry
for the delay
yo we gotta go we gotta go
hello Corrine you go out no Japanese
tonight I got you fill-in instead okay
thank you
all right
big guy right
I wish this weapon always fell like this
hack that sucker explains it this time
revived what there's someone else solar
I guess we're gonna have to clear this
stuff out okay yep
or at least some of it solar is actually
really dangerous over there so be
careful milk waterfall can we stop it
oh here we go
now a boy of course
we should go we're clear and present
danger hmm
I can't move I want to say Harrison Ford
no okay okay you want to do that same
strategy we did last time yep dark all
right chill up top how much try to get
as many circles I think as we can
because we left some behind right yeah
well I didn't go behind get back up top
is there a way to get back on top I
think I think two people should stay
behind
cuz I can go on the right and then I'm
done and I can't get back up so if two
people stay behind then why does it do
this thou shalt not pass a solar so like
I couldn't go on the left I can go on
the right someone else can do that
save a solar yeah be a little late
I should employ boy
after this guy dies they're gonna spawn
more I'm gonna go down okay well you
guys so Aaron you take the left when we
get the circles and he jumps
nice nap right Ingram still are
can't get rid of this guy's shield it's
still Arkwright yeah I'm out of art
there's solar - right now it's solar now
alright I'm gonna go through the rings
I'm gonna look I can't go to these left
ones like I should go right yeah I don't
know how far back you can get like if
you take the ones on the on your right
I'll try my best
wow I just broke my legs
to all that got that one I also got to
see so as long as you jump through at
the same time I think can you get any
more if not we should just go I can't
all right let's go yeah we should be I
guess we should all be jumping through
at the same time so we could try that in
the next one mm-hmm although is the next
one the the drill no it's that area with
the two Centurions okay this one we can
skip this stuff right so just go by
everything I lied just run past them
hopefully
oh it's solar watch out and do
just go just go we should be able to
just don't get shot up writer because
they're solar are you good yep I'm good
schway are we going Boyd I try to go
through this hole yeah there's a void so
we just gotta get to that one spot where
the those two big dudes are yeah yeah
yeah okay so not do not get the do not
get the Rings yet are their rings here's
one right here don't get the Rings yes
we gotta clear it out
how far back was that oh we skipped all
those rings huh
I don't even know okay cool that's why
we didn't do it Rob oh release if these
freaking Caesar I don't even remember
that hundred percent we skip those rings
Wow
where they at though I don't know we
haven't we haven't rigor to press
forward okay so the ball thing what is
it on wait why does it the triangles
back here though do we have to kill
something that's way far back
this is so awkward [ __ ] dude I don't
know if we should have gone that far
yeah I don't get it
this doesn't make sense I don't know
what happened it's the circles all a
order damn yeah whatever it's weird we
did this before well we did we did we
hang on that right side maybe we had to
kill that stuff and I like I don't know
it's just pressed forward right it wants
us to go back up there no I'm looking at
it right here okay
just a bug we bugged does anyone in chat
know if we're bugged this is looks like
a bug I mean I'm we're freakin here
nothing's here you want to restart again
I mean we're here we can't engage that I
guess so maybe we had to kill that stuff
up top I don't know why we would have to
it says press forward all right so we're
starting over I don't know it's the
thing if the marker is here and it says
press forward we're pressing forward
okay cool
okay I'm seriously like over this right
now I don't like I don't know what I
don't know what's wrong with that part
right there that's lame like what were
we supposed to do there I don't I don't
get it the best shots are to not do what
we've been doing so far can you keep it
with pride we gotta we can't because
then the you have to kill two blood
Legion commanders just to be able to
jump over the the ravine yeah and those
guys weren't spawning so either we do
have to kill the axe guys
gube you should have multiple people
jump through the rings at one time
before it disappears and it adds 30
seconds each time like each ring per
person it can be up to three people if
you like all bunnyhop at the same time
so we should actually really be like
trying to coordinate jumping through
multiple rings that one I mean or at
least on certain areas right like the
first one I think we could do
here we go welcome to nurses must be
careful of that one minute artist he
actually has void
they just one of those from now on with
this hack to all the ads everywhere it's
art ya thinks it's my manners
it's being real annoying
you know we go here we go for the fourth
time here we go hi Rob says curse vixx
he got that backwards curse nui says hot
Rob yeah I know
the Ark's though yeah no okay
must be solar actually
I avoid but we can go
wonder if maybe only one of us should
jump down later right like you mentioned
so I'm just gonna let Aaron jump down
anything and then I'll try to get as
many with you up top sound good I see
that again I said I was saying two of us
should stay up top like you said yeah
yeah stay up top with you and then
hopefully Aaron just drops down I guess
yeah I was weird that thing wasn't there
this time
because it's doing like no damage solar
yep
I don't have any all right well I'm
gonna hit
long range it's gonna change I guess
he's staying up here with you so I'm
gonna drop down okay Aaron stay up here
with me don't go down we're gonna hit
these rings you get the ones on the left
later not now not now okay this morning
it's void
I don't think he's on the college I
don't know what kind of minutes I'm
wasting now okay no I don't I just want
to say that arc yep
Wow
oh [ __ ] that you got damnit you down yes
Chuck come for you no it's fine it's
fine just she's guys he's about just
it's solar
I'm gonna respawn I got him I'm gonna
respawn and then we're gonna jump
through the ring now together all right
what are we doing here what do you want
going on the right you go on the left
tire hold on or we both should jump
through this one right here no no no no
come here we're both gonna jump through
this ready three two one I'm going on
the left he said yeah Oh God I take this
higher oh I screwed my jump up god damn
it's all right
I'm normally pretty good oh please
mantle something okay Aaron I got this
one yeah you're good we got all them it
looks like except for one I'm gonna go
grab it if you can make it through I got
that one all right
we're get a little good we went through
a bunch of these together Aaron just not
bad cuz you start with 11
my advice cube is just try to kill
everything and then run through the
things the Rings together
if you jump through them together you'll
get more time 30 seconds each time so
you kill the [ __ ] I don't know I'm gonna
follow this gosh darn singing approach
the drilling site it's fine this time I
think it's because some of the ads
weren't there last time or something is
my hope yeah yes I also did not see what
modifier was I don't think it's arc oh
no it is definitely are
hi sparrow
boy groups all right
yep all the stuff that we need this bond
fund is currently void film I'll focus
on the guys in the lab
john-boy boy
alright one side down right now it's a
arc okay good I super then you say yeah
fine if you want to go for it clear out
the left of the other side you know
where the boss guy is yeah all right
cool
alright let me come get that first one
with you
Aaron really should be back here too but
he's never gonna hear us so whatever
it's fine it's just frustrating
yeah alright three two one oh okay
you go I don't know jump through that
one if you can with me jump through this
one cool well you want to get high one
is really high when I see ya [ __ ] are
you ready oh I was not gonna here do
this short one
alright three two one go and then we're
gonna do this one three two one
hopefully you got that just go three two
one let's go back and try to get that
one in the center I guess or this high
one it's up to you they're collapsing
[ __ ] alright whatever
let's go we got nine minutes good thing
Aaron was over there helping us it is
what it is as everyone's back he said oh
yeah yeah you totally had her back there
and thanks solar dude alert if he was
there we would have got to like 10
minutes because we got like three or
four oh god
I think they want their drill back
oh I saw solar anymore but yeah it's boy
they're a doges I got milk over enemy
what what I'm Park High School grenade
he's also our so
more dogs
oh I just killed myself I'm so sorry
I need to get revived in like seven
seconds oh that's fine okay I just
jumped off those amazing play damn we
did enough - who cares it ran [ __ ] this
is why you gotta coordinate stuff better
yeah there it is that's salt a yep I
mean when you have a guy that's not
running through rings I'm gonna be
pretty salty about it how long are you
guys I'll wait
gimme just keep going yeah yeah go
through I think we have more time than
last time though but I'm not
oh god not this no I ran into you you
spawn right here no I'm all the way back
there just go ahead I literally ran into
your back and could not go forward damn
it that's fine just keep what are we on
do you know I don't know I wasn't even
paying attention to be honest I think
you can just run past these guys because
it says cross the dig site okay I'm
gonna do it or you can hold your ghost
to see it that's if I'm lying to you or
not yeah cuz we got it basically no
aren't sick I killed myself again shy
way or keep going
now I'll keep going [ __ ]
because I died twice trying to make this
super jump
that's funny I never had problems in the
beta but I don't I I mean is it me but
like it shouldn't just smack e in the
freaking or is that part of the
challenge are no air breaking it find
out I'm goes it go and try again maybe
no is not the way okay
luckily I have these boots I think
alright keep going
okay I keep going here we might be able
to make up time I don't know it's hard
to say okay I just got I got I got punch
it - alright well I made it here oh good
I just go then I guess I don't know
we'll just keep trying cuz this is our
last guy I mean literally nice Matt Mike
enjoy I mean keep going going what like
my waiting for you guys I'm responding
now let's go
these dudes are mean
which one probably means I'm probably
annoying him it's fine the angry one I'm
not you're not annoying me
no not you someone you chat I don't just
beat that Wow
it's got mad punted true gravities now
no no no no let's kill some of it and
we'll see what we can do in terms of
jumping through as many as we can on
camera well we had three minutes last
time so we're actually still ahead of
last time so technically where's Aaron
though is he here
Oh what oh please don't die tonight you
die no yeah I'm done it knocked me so
far back
oh he triggered the okay he triggered it
I think it may be launched me through it
it was my fault no that's not your fault
dude I was hoping that Aaron would wait
on these rings but now we just got I'm
gonna go on the top right go for it dude
it's already gonna be like a real sketch
because he triggered it like pretty
early
damn we were freaking counting on that I
know yeah that's all right just try to
get weekend to see if you can get like
one more
by 44 we might still be able to do it
just push through it's true if you're
already there channels through
if you get this jump yeah I'll join you
in a second I have no idea what's on
here just IGN employees nothing special
oh I don't know what to tell you Solar
solar ok I'm gonna save my solar all
right yep all right you ready let's do
it
- hopefully Aaron joins us must have
been from like the drill she's at arc
next I can't remember the order
notice in that stage places to be young
alright well we go four and a half
minutes to try again see how it goes
by the way his head is his weak spot yep
shush super him when I get hit hit dark
sure sorry go for it if you can reach
him there
he is on other side now middle there
he's immune goodbye
we're gonna drop down here in a second
signal
3:46 that slightly better than the last
time I think we might be able to do it
show yourself vex rocket immune gonna go
thing right now I'm using hammer you
might be able to
I'm out of solar all right we're gonna
drop down one more time this is good
Aaron I hope that you hear me when it
goes arc I need you to just hopefully
you have super if you don't have super
than it is what it is
but I would love if you could tighten
this mash and shorter car Jim Boyd
our boys back
blinded to architects I think so yeah if
you can get a grenade on him Rob that
I'll get a grenade and I got my Rockets
as well it's art art too far away
nope oh god stop okay here we go
Oh Eric what a scrub Wow
what is going on if I Rockets please
it's one hit nope no Rockets
I'm so sorry Rob we got Adam we fit I
failed four Rockets and we did it but we
got it we did it Thank You Robin cold
hard cold hard legit my cold huh from
the woman who left me shot like to his
left
long day scrub all right we did it
all right you dance now salt the earth I
got two rewards which is pretty good
it's not better gloves which is awesome
ooh 273 hot feet and not work like I
don't know with only 289 gloves and a to
79 helm
hey man something's broke did you talk
in the wrong guy no something's broken I
just got screwed Rob well I didn't get
many yeah like I only got like a nice
set of feet but like everything okay so
let me tell you actually it shouldn't
have done that
on on this what I was gonna say is like
if you have two of the same character
it'll like easily a reader Twitter DM
it'll easily screw one of your
characters in terms of like what they
can get like I'll show you I helped
explain lower level drops okay let's
take a look I'm pretty sure it's the
double it's the double it's the double
Titan Titan that's really wrecking me
right now let's see maybe calm knowledge
now but it's new you have a 75 minutes
goes by blah blah this is a vacation I
explain the math everyone's complaining
about lower cosmic ocean
I thought I saw already thing everyone
complaining about like some strikes and
stuff being no I shouldn't have done
that
like neurosis in chat like that
shouldn't it shouldn't have affected it
because my power ful drop should still
be as high as my actual power but the
weird thing about having two of the same
characters is that it like it's somehow
doesn't recognize one versus the other
and like it thinks that like you're
actually lower than you really are
which is like really weird so basically
don't have two of the same class like I
do because you're just gonna get rekt
essentially so yeah
also don't miss rock it's like I did
like so in theory right like you should
be able to get this powerful here you
could save it if you want to rob because
maybe you're gonna do some other
activities tonight okay but in theory
right like this should reads like like a
really high for me but it only reads to
89 I'm like pretty sure I'm like higher
than that so at least my powerful gear
isn't wrecked yet but apparently my
nightfall gears has been wrecked so hold
off on this that's up to you I mean I'm
gonna do it yeah like I got you're
saying basically I got a bunch of other
things to just went up I have two of the
same character and it's working fine
just went up three to four power level
by actually paying attention paying
attention how so actually inspect items
I mean I have a bunch of plus five
damage modifiers like not on this I mean
I do on my nameless midnight like I
don't see how that's gonna do anything
different this obviously has plus five
damage a bunch of my armor has plus five
saw that Titan Mark had no mod so you're
saying mod everything yeah I have a five
mod think all my stuff has a mod right
now that's a five mod that's a mod
that's and well it's like I have mods on
everything I already have everything
modded oh so you're saying it's is it
because my mods are boosting me and then
that is what's actually affecting what
the hell just happened we got
disconnected from one key servers we've
done broken we done broke it I don't
know why that is the case I mean we can
go take a look at this powerful gear
I'll turn it in I don't really care
yeah my mods could be faking my power
level which is what is ultimately
potentially affecting my gear drops are
based off of base level power okay that
makes sense so this is yeah so I'm like
around 289 but then okay if that's true
Dan or neurosis if I'm - okay there you
go so it's only 289 so yeah then I'm
gonna continue to get to 89 which will
only help me on my chest and my helm and
my mark so I really don't wanna get
gloves so I basically got the worst shop
I could get in in the nightfall which is
fine and then for some reason you just
get another piece of gear that doesn't
do anything anyways that's good
knowledge so basically yeah can you
explain though okay so you remember how
I said mods will fake boost your light
or it will boost it right in the game so
my powers is 288 but really I'm faking
it right because I have so many mods
stacked up and what neurosis is saying
in chat is basically if you your drops
are determined by your base level - the
mods so really even though I feel like
I'm a lot higher I'm not really as high
as I am so but so your drops reflected
as if you had no mods on them yes and I
believe so that explains and then the
items you got yes you're like what yeah
because basically right next to your
arms all right yeah it makes sense right
I actually had only a sense because this
is 289 right but if you add the 5 mod to
it which my gloves already have its 294
right but so like what I really need is
to get a 289 chest which would be
actually amazing for me because I could
then get it to 294 like this one
with a mod so in theory like here I'll
just turn this thing because whatever
Yolo all right we got a helmet another
merciless that's cool
actually getting a merciless doesn't
really help me oh it did 294 okay so we
got a helm which is pretty good right
because technically I have a mod in it
right so technically that helm is
actually only 281
but this helm is 289 right sorry this is
getting kinda confusing and then I can I
can put like this modifier on it right
cuz all right we'll just do it for
science because just for the stream just
to see so now this helm is 294 but
really it's 289 because you know i
modded it so right now yes and as Dan
mentioned all the Blues that I start
getting will slowly crawl higher higher
because I'm higher light so I'll
actually leveled up my third character
really fast because I moved all of these
weapons over and then the armor jobs
just in even though they're blues like
my warlock was there a 270 in like an
hour
anyways though that's a long like thingy
of explanation anyway 70 in an hour from
when last night after I beat story what
yeah that's crazy how fast
yeah well it's because I'm cheating in a
way because I already have these really
high level weapons and those are those
make my character higher and the game
thinks I'm higher so then it drops
higher armor yeah make sense so that's a
quick breakdown on our mercy like I
could blow this up now how long just
take to get to 20 Oh actually I could
leave it on another character how long
does it take to get to 20 by yourself or
if you do it with another like a team
mate or a high level person I think it's
like six to eight hours could be faster
Dan what do you do with here that has +5
moderate II you infuse it yeah you
infuse it with other stuff gube because
it'll add 5 to whatever you infuse it to
so like say I would do some more math
right I love it
so technically right speaking I have a 5
modifier in this so really this is a bad
example because it's so high ok let's
take this 271 it doesn't have a 5
modifier I could
I'm not going to but let's say you got a
282 drop or sorry let's say this had the
five modifier in its 276 mhm and then
you got a 282 drop mm-hmm if you infuse
the 276 into the 280 it'll take it - it
should take it - I'm I'm at 280 285 I
think because it would take it to
whatever it is right it infuses straight
so it's like okay I don't care if you
had a mod because it doesn't count
there's actually a 271 into a 280 it
makes it to 80 and then you add the 5 so
it's 285 so there you go that was really
long anyways we did it that's that's
good that's good stream in my book -
good stream and we went through
frustrations apologies to the stream for
my frustrations I could have been a
better team player Rob here shut up was
a good good team player hey that's my
first job how did you how did you like
it
it's pretty intense I tried I was trying
to like team up with some randoms last
night but didn't go through just because
of the app or whatever it was but I
don't even know if I would do it with
random people uh it'll get better
I mean voice I'm I've done by guys from
gang guys like I don't know if I would
have I was gonna see if I could do it
without voice chat but you need poise
chat yeah I understand I didn't know
those rings were a factor that's the
saying like that ring [ __ ] was big yeah
so I mean like every week it's gonna
have different modifiers so obviously
those will dictate how you approach the
nightfall yeah I cannot get this thing
to open oh it's probably just asleep
sorry I'm trying to turn back the
computer on that's actually like helping
us dream this thing there we go we're
back anyways thanks so much everybody
Dusty's children first episode the
struggles of the nightfall the real
struggles but we got robbed through his
first nightfall was pretty cool we had
Aaron out there who hasn't done a knife
all so far in destiny to get through
there
wasn't even on boys college with us it's
just kind of guess I guess I like to
imagine he was eating a sandwich yeah
probably
and so yeah pretty good don't forget
Friday we have Destiny's children the UK
are gonna be doing their adventures as
they play through destiny two together
two more Dave and Lucy so definitely
check that out it'll be on the youtubes
we have the lobby tomorrow which is
pretty awesome so yeah stay tuned the
bet for that that's at 11 a.m.
appreciate you guys all hanging out with
me and Rob yeah thanks we your destiny -
stuff's going well for you guys and we
have a bunch of destiny - guides and
content coming out so tomorrow's a big
day out right tomorrow's a big day right
yeah definitely all right
the raid is tomorrow we're not streaming
the raid just so you guys know so I can
get that out there we're not doing that
so but I hope you guys enjoy the radio
if you guys are doing it see you guys
later bye bye
[Music]
you